ready
uh yeah next up we are excited to have
seong mei talking about the type of free
energy
yeah it's my pleasure to
talk at sentence and this talk is about
the local convexity of type energy and
amp convergence for a
for
particular
typical model for
bayesian inference in high dimension
and the results talk just talk about
about the niche initial search phase is
hard well i would like to talk about
while the final search phase is simple
and this is a joint work with michael
celetano and the dolphin and it's on
it's based on
prior work with zolfan and andre mari
so the motivation is to do variational
base and inference and while there are
two point of view in terms of
vibrational inference one point of view
is optimizing a variational free energy
and another point of view is to use
iterative algorithms
by additional free energy for example
the vibrational base beta free energy or
the type of energy interactive
algorithms include repropagation
expectation propagation message passing
and approximate message passing
okay so this method has been established
for more than 20 years have been written
into software and works well in practice
when people actually do
based on inference
the theoretical challenge uh are that
well
uh can i show that minimizer of the free
energy really approximate the base
proteome
and well it's the landscape of the free
energy
are good and
whether iterative algorithms converge
okay so
in this talk i would like to talk about
a specific high dimensional statistical
model which is the c2 synchronization in
the
weak signal regime
okay and we believe that while the whole
story can be moved to
other statistical models like
generalized linear models or like spec
matrix models but here today we are
focusing on the system synchronization
problems and we are going to look at the
landscape of the type energy and we are
going to look at whether iterative
algorithms will converge
okay so what is z2 synchronization
well we have a signal x in in dimension
where each coordinate is uniformly plus
one minus one
okay so this is the prior of the signal
and
we observe
a
noisy pairwise product of x i and xj
observe this y-i-j
the noise is assumed to be gaussian
and while lambda is the signal-to-noise
ratio is assumed to be fixed
and the dimension goes to infinity
so that means well
there is not an estimator that can be
consistent okay so you cannot have fully
recover this x you can only estimate
this x up to a constant error as then
goes to infinity
in matrix notation we have matrix y and
by n matrix it is a noisy goe
perturbation of the spike
okay so the task is to estimate this x
given y and because of the degeneracy of
the z2 well perhaps we can say that we
estimate this matrix which is x x
transpose
okay so
well
yeah so this is the setting and the
perhaps we can look at square loss it
doesn't matter i mean perhaps well let's
say we look at square laws and
well look at what is the
best estimator what does the best
estimator can do
for lambda less than one
this is information theoretically
impossible this is
established results and for lambda
greater than one
estimation can be possible and
efficient we can use just special
estimator
and this is called the
pc transition
and
well but the optimal estimator the base
as is the bs estimator which is the
posterior expectation of x-axis
transpose given y
okay so
here there is a plot of the limiting mse
achieved by the base estimator which is
the posterior expectation of excess
transpose and the pc estimator which is
a spectral estimator and you can see
that well the blue line is the base
and it actually smaller means square
error
and the pc estimator and the threshold
both of them is at one
okay so
well the base estimator is very good and
while people have shown good properties
for this base estimator but the problem
is
the question today we have to ask is how
to compute this base estimator
well definitely it's a high dimensional
integration problem
so we want to approximate it instead of
compute exactly and what people do is
vibrational inference
but there are two point of view
directional free energy and iterative
algorithm
and well the type energy is the
correct free energy to think about this
problem and well there is this
approximate message passing algorithm
which are also standard in the
literature so in this talk i would like
to analyze these two objects
what's the type free energy okay so
well the variational free energy point
of view is that you want to find a
function maps
from the solid cube
to a real number such that the minimizer
of this function
we call it and hatch it corresponds to
the base estimator so and height and
head transpose well should be the base
estimator this is a function we hope to
find
and the mean field variational base this
is a naive
free energy people use in practice which
is just obviously it can be derived from
the kl minimization principle is just a
summation of entropy term and an energy
term
but this diagonal base the energy will
not be the correct free energy
in a sense that while the minimizer will
not correspond to the posterior amine
so um then well there is another free
energy called the tap the tech energy
tap means while the there are three
physicists
told us anderson palmer they
when they look at spin glass the sk
model they derive a free energy
uh like this
okay so the difference between the tap
the tefl energy and the directional base
is that there is an additional enzyme
correction term
is business term while
physicist conjecture that the minimizer
of this type of energy will correspond
to the right posterior mean
okay so
well
slow dis is
in some in some sense is a conjecture
and we would like to understand well
whether the minimizer of the type energy
uh gives the posterior means and also we
want to understand the landscape of this
type energy so
one property is that this is a
non-complex strategy function
and there will be bad local minimizers
well the question is whether it has a
nice landscape and whether the global
minimizer corresponds to this
this is the first question we would like
to ask
another question they would like to ask
is about this approximate message
passing algorithm
well
it has a long history and the amp
algorithm of this problem is just given
by this iterative equation
the interesting okay so the important
thing is that the k plus 1 iteration
depends on the case iteration and the k
minus 1 iteration
okay another basic property of this np
iteration is that the fixed point of a
and p corresponds to the stationary
point of
path energy so this is just by trivial
algebra
and
well another property is that while this
emp is not a descent algorithm on the
type free energy okay so it's not like
waiting on type of energy is doing
something
um
some other things
but while there are good properties of
this mp in a sense that people can show
that
uh the following property okay so
uh
people can show the convergence of amps
starting from special initialization in
the sense that
while if we look at the fixed k and look
at the case iteration of amp compute the
distance between mk mk transpose minus
okay so bs estimator
for billions terms okay so this is a
error
and first we take n goes to infinity we
can get a number epsilon k we can fully
characterize this number
and then
uh as k goes to infinity this number
goes to zero okay
so this convergence is not in the sense
that well if you have a fixed sample
size n you have a fixed instance you run
amp it converts to some
some point that corresponds to the phase
estimator
but it's a little bit different you
first take sample size go to infinity
and then you take k goes to infinity
okay so
this characterization allow to well
characterize uh extract a lot of
information of the base estimator so
it's a very good result but well in
terms of optimization while it's still
not clear whether well if you run emp
for
forever rather if you convert to some
fixed point
so
people try to analyze well okay so this
result is established using state
evolution analysis which is standard
well
uh
apparently it's a standard tool to deal
with amp
and people try to improve the
concentration
from amp to static evolution but the
stage of art analysis only able to like
k the number of equations to be
little log n or log of n
um
so
this number of iteration is not enough
to show
uh the convergence of amp
so the quest second question we have to
ask is that well whether we can show the
convergence of emp algorithm for fixed
instance as k goes to infinity
so these are the questions
we'd like to answer in this tab and here
is a numerical simulation basically says
that well
the conjecture is that well the
landscape of the type of energy is quite
nice and amp converge
so this blue curve is the residual of
amp versus the number of equations
you can see that well it converts very
well and for different
uh
initialization
uh it all covers the same point
and we have some other algorithms which
also converge and we i will describe it
later
okay so first uh the main result uh
uh was by like zolvan me and andrea
three years ago
uh it characterized the global landscape
of the type energy so it says that well
suppose we look at the critical points
of the type of energy below some
threshold
then well when lambda when the signal to
noise ratio is large enough but this
lambda zero doesn't depend on n
so it's still in the weak region and we
can hopefully carry the signal
but when lambda is greater than this
threshold
we can show that
so for any critical point below a
threshold is close to the bs estimator
okay so this result well there is a
geometric uh
cloud of these results okay it says that
all the critical points below a
threshold are close to the base
estimator
okay so this well so the landscape looks
like this there could be bad local
measures above this threshold but if you
look at critical points below this
threshold all these are close to the
base estimator
by the way the population minimizer is
not at the biggest estimator the
population minimizer may be somewhere
else
okay so
this is the result uh we showed
three years ago
okay but well we can in this in this
result we cannot exclude bad localizers
near the bss meter we can only show that
well if there is a critical point all
these critical points are close to the
bss meter
and this result is established using the
clockwise formula which i will describe
it
soon
okay so
then we have these results while just to
exclude but local measures near the
phase estimator i mean uh we can show
that there is exists a unique local
minimizer near this base estimator
so this is by like michael so and me
and
we show that well when lambda is greater
than one one is the information
theoretical threshold of this problem
so we can show that with high
probability there exists a unique
critical point and unique minimizer they
are the same m star of this type energy
up to a plus one minus sign because of
the symmetry
such that well this estimator and this
minimizer is close to the base
estimator
and this type energy is strongly complex
uh in a small neighborhood and this
neighborhood is not so small i mean
this
the size allow us to prove some
algorithmic give some algorithmic
guarantee
okay
so
while the geometric figure picture is
like this we show that well
uh
near the
base estimator well there is actually
just a unique local minimizer
there's not so many
local minimizers even in this
neighborhood
okay so
this is the result for the landscape of
the type free energy so you can imagine
that well with this geometric result
well there
will be a
polynomial time algorithm to find these
unique logarithmizers
well the first the gas would be green
descent but well actually green in sense
may not work very well but well
we come up with its natural gradient
sense but well first let's look at well
the iterative algorithm first is like
this
amp algorithm
well you can write it in this form and
uh
there is this nitro gradient descent
algorithm which is greedy descent
preconditioned by the feature
information
and while people also call it the
bregman gradient descent or mirror
design their many name of this algorithm
so basically this algorithm is doing
like gradient descent but well in a
different geometry like
while you are calculating the gradient
of half energy but you update it
in the mirror space
so
well you can look at the difference of
amp and natural grading descent are very
similar the difference is just that
while there is a step size in the
natural gradient sense if you take the
steps at e to equal to one
well this is even closer and the only
difference is that here the time index
is k minus 1 is correct to be the time
indexes k
so that in n g d
uh the k plus one situation only depends
on the case iteration not the k minus y
integration
okay so i think well
uh ngd is more natural a more natural
optimization algorithm if you don't know
about this statistical model if you only
if you're only in the optimization
community perhaps you prefer this
ngd than the amp algorithm for
optimizing this have energy
and the good thing about ngd is that
it's descent on the type of energy
so well
uh first result we can show that a
hybrid algorithm will converge to a
minimizer m star i mean m star is the
global minimizer of the type energy so
the algorithm is that first we need to
do spectral spectrometrization well this
is unavoidable because of the symmetry
you need to run a and p for
t steps this t is constant but large so
that it drives you to the local
neighborhood
and then we continue to run natural
gradient sense with steps as eta it
shows that when lambda is greater than
the
information theoretical threshold while
these
this iterates will converge to
m star and minus m star so this
convergence is for a fixed ins for fixed
instance
and for fixed signal size n
uh it's different from the convergence
of mp
result using analyze using evolution
okay
so
well this is a hybrid algorithm okay so
we show that well if you do special
installation amp
go to the neighbor local neighborhood
and then continue to run ngd it will
convert to this unique immunizer
and the convergence of ngd is purely due
to the geometric property of this type
of energy it's due to the relative
smoothness and relative strong
complexity
and well how about if we just run amp or
just run ngds themselves but not when
the hybrid algorithm processes people
prefer prefer to do
and we can show that well the lambda is
greater than a particular than the
threshold which is greater than one we
cannot drive down this threshold to one
that means high probability either
spectral neutralized amp or spectrum ngd
converts the minimizer m star
okay so i mean the proof of this is much
easier than
uh the proof of landline is greater than
one
really either like it could be that uh
you know for
for some instance like for some for some
instance amp works and then for some
other instances
these are two theorems one theorem is
like amp will converge another theorem
is indeed real conversion
so they both do oh oh both okay okay
actually you suppose yeah okay cool
thank you sorry i don't know i mean it
makes sense now but okay i got it okay
okay sorry it's all sick
yeah
okay
in retrospect it's a very foolish
interpretation
it's true if you choose one randomly
it works with high probability
that's uh that's so hard to show
okay so well how about well perhaps
another uh question is like suppose we
want well definitely just use emp when
lambda is greater than iq threshold
rather it will converge
what we can show is that well when
lambda is greater than one
uh this m star is a symmetrically stable
fixed point of a and p
in the sense that while there exists a
small neighborhood near the flow
minimizer such that emp initialized in
this neighborhood will converge climb
star but the problem is that this delta
may depend on n it we cannot make this
quantitative delta
okay so the open problem is that can you
show that special interest emp converge
as long as the lambda is greater than
the information theoretical threshold
this is what we don't know
well this is a conductor to be true
but we don't know how to show it
okay so here we just want to show some
universality results so the theorem is
based on that noise is gaussian matrix
but we tried other noise matrix and well
the
empirically the result is the same
okay so i would like to briefly talk
about the proof
um so
uh first let me show the technical
challenge so technical challenge is that
well
there's no uniform convergence happening
okay so
because the signal to noise ratio is not
so large well if the signal to noise
ratio is large enough what will happen
is that the empirical risk will be unif
the uniform converts the population risk
the
first second
zero first and second order derivative
of the empirical risk
you will be close to
the
the population risk uh supreme over the
m okay so this doesn't happen so this is
a difficulty if this happens then we can
just look at the neighborhood of
population risk which is x
the 2x and then analyze this
neighborhood this is a deterministic
neighborhood and very easy to show a
geometric property
but the difficulty is that well when
signal to noise ratio is of order one
the empirical reason measure will be far
away from the population measure and
then the the improvising measure will be
at a random location
so it's hard to deal with this
minimizer of the empirical risk and then
well you want to not only locate where
is the empirical is measured but also
talk about the local geometry around
this empirical reasoning measure which
is not
an easy task
okay so the technical tool we use the
first technical tool is the calculus
formula okay so the formula is that well
suppose well we want to count to the
number of critical points of random work
of a running function in some particular
region well we can compute its
expectation using this formula
so
the technical difficulty of dealing with
this formula is just to calculate the
expectation of determining of highest
end condition on gradient equal to zero
and
well in this paper we have shown that
well there is an upper bound of the
number of critical points and the rate
to the function s star
okay we have a analytical formula for
this star and by analyzing this star
well we can show that all local
minimizers below some threshold are
close to the glowing measure
okay
so
so
the global geometry can be
calculated can be
analyzed using these
characterized formula and give it a
hammer bounce
and you can see that well
this without this
doesn't exclude bad local minimizers
not bad but this doesn't exclude
the possibility that there are many
local minimizers near the global
minimizer
so another technical tool we use is
the conditional gaussian comparison
inequality
to exclude those local minimizers near
the global immunizer
so we need to analyze the gaussian
process gaussian is because the noise is
gaussian
okay so we need to analyze the high cn
the least eigenvalue of the high cn
when this m is in the neighborhood of
the
m star
and the quantitative neighborhood of m
star conditional on that well the type
energy
the quick the m star is a critical point
of this type of energy
and the good thing of this gaussian
process is that even if the conditioning
on this linear okay conditioning on this
constraint
this type of energy is still a gaussian
but the hyphen of the path energy is
still a gaussian process
it's a finite rank spect okay so the
highest end conditional gradient equal
to zero is a finite rank spec goe matrix
okay so using the gaussian comparison
inequality the selection inequality we
are able to show a high probability
lower bound for the rescued heisen
which is given by this vibrational
formula
and
we are able to show that this
vibrational formula is greater than zero
okay so
well
that means type energy will be locally
strongly convex near some m star
okay but
okay so showing this result has some
practical challenges
and we need some smart idea to show this
and
well
the first technical challenge is to
control the empirical distribution of
coordinate of this m star to control
this we use again the slapping plus
characterize to give give it a tight
control
and then we need to analyze this
milestone formula to show that it's
greater than zero
and well
handling this variational formula
uh well takes
uh some effort and well first need to
handle the bulk and then show the spike
doesn't affect the bulk and
yeah
and then there is another non-trivial
thing which is that well here this m
star
is at a random location okay so
this
high probability lower bound is for a
fixed m star
so you need to have a union bound over m
star to be a critical point
okay so
it's not like well you have
through this you are you are done you
need to
you take a union bound or i'm star which
could be a critical point
and to do this while there is a
non-trivial vary natural argument we
need to have a clever argument to obtain
a union bound or m star using the
characterized formula again
okay so this is
the
technical technical difficulty uh of
dealing with the landscape of the
pacific energy and then we have well how
to show the convergence of natural green
descent while this is due to purely due
to a geometric property
well because of the landscape we have
shown for type energy we can show the
relative smoothness and relative strong
complexity and then the optimization
simple optimization argument well
non-random agreement will give implied
convergence of natural gradient descent
okay and how about convergence of emp
well
the way to show it is first to write
this mp iteration into this form okay so
we stack mk plus 1 and k as a function
of mk and mk minus 1 analyze the linear
rise amp operator but while this is a
little bit different from what people
did in the literature people did is to
linearize it in the uninformative point
and here we linearize it m star which is
well conceptually the global minimum
condition on this
type of energy
is
a critical point
and while we are able to analyze this
um
amp operator okay so
i think it's a non-trivial argument
we are able to show that when lambda is
greater than one
with high probability the spectral norm
of this amp the gradient of amp the
jacobian of amp operator
at m star
is less than one so that this implies
the asymptotic stability
uh
of amp algorithm at m star
and when lambda greater than lambda 0
is high probability we can show the
operator norm found of this jacobian of
amp
operator where m is in a neighborhood in
a quantitative neighborhood of m star
so that this will imply the global
convergence
of
of amp algorithm
okay so this is uh what i have to talk
about today so we have conclusion in the
following
type energy has no space local minimum
below a threshold when lambda is greater
than a big threshold it's locally
strongly convex near the base estimator
when lambda is greater than its
threshold a hybrid algorithm
a spectral amp and ngd algorithm will
converge to m star and well when lambda
is greater than lambda zero well both
these algorithm will converge and amp is
but synthetically stable at m star when
lambda is greater than one my open
question is like can we show that amp
converge
when lambda is greater than one well and
we believe the proof strategy can be
extended to other high-dimensional
statistics
this is all i've talked about today
thanks so much for the great talk uh i
guess i'm thinking about sort of the
models that we've seen sort of maybe
like sparse spikes and stuff along the
lines of what we have heard in this
workshop before so can you maybe say a
few words about how the geometry will
change so for example if the spike is
sparse then do you expect the geometry
around the maximizer to change or do you
think it will change like
along the initialization and how would
so
if you sparse the sparse if sparsity is
still
linear in n
then
i would guess the geometry will be the
same
uh the
this will be still still
the whole result can be carried through
when the sparsity is linear in n but
there is a hard phase right
oh okay okay yeah there will be a hard
phase and uh well i will guess that well
in the
fixed point when the fixed in the state
evolution has a stable fixed point
then the
for that fixed point there will be a
unique minimizer of amp fixed point and
that amp fixed point is stable sure i
don't know about what happened for the
unstable fixed point of the evolution
other questions
okay let's thank song again
[Applause]
so now we have lunch and we'll be back
at 1